well there's a difference between doing
and allowing there's a difference
between allowing a bad thing to happen
and being the cause of a bad thing to
happen but it gets even more complicated
than that because like you've got to
decide like
how are you defining the difference
between doing and allowing like what
what really is the difference there for
example
if i walk up to somebody who is attached
to a life support machine and i unplug
them have i killed them or i allowed
them to die
alex bloody o'connor how are you
chris i am i'm well all the better for
seeing you as they say
uh it's been it's been too it's been too
long i haven't seen you in person
since we went to that event in london
and i can't think how long ago that was
now where you made me do the yoga that
you seem to be telling
everyone in their dog about and that
photo of me that photo of me that you
keep posting is like you know the one of
beyonce that she wanted to disappear
from the internet
that's my version of that just me trying
to work out how to put my leg under the
yeah it was a nightmare um but yeah it's
a shame it's good to be speaking to you
again even if it's a public conversation
yeah i know man it is uh that was one
hell of a weekend
one one one hell of a weekend i've got
i've got the full length
one hour yoga form
recording both of us doing it side by
side and i'm considering offering it out
to the highest bidder i'm pretty certain
there's some people on the internet
some fairly sort of prominent uh
debaters of yours that would pay good
money
for that kind of ammunition yeah yeah i
i i do worry about some of the
ammunition that my friends have on me
and
people they could sell it to i think
maybe i could release it as a patreon
exclusive or something that might be a
good or you could release it as a
patreon exclusive that and then these
patrons go yeah they'll jump over to you
yeah i don't know um we'll see but you
know i haven't even seen that video
so god knows what are the weird shapes i
tried to move my body into
hey it was graceful it was it was your
first time you know no one's good at the
first time
no one's no one's no yeah no one's good
at the first time as they say
um yeah that was well that was february
man that was a while ago
was that february yeah man it's crazy
it's crazy world out there
um i've been getting a bit of flack for
it actually because you know um
speaking because i i'm we're going to be
talking about ethics today
um uh because i when you reached out to
me and i i was on your podcast before
and we talked about veganism which was
the first time we properly spoke and
that was ages ago now
um but of course talking about veganism
requires ethics more broadly as
an underlying but hopefully i can sway
you in an ethical direction that
that puts you off the idea of sharing
those videos with me online but we'll
see where it goes
okay i see how you're circling this
background now i am a bad friend if that
video ever surfaces
anywhere um so okay ethics morality
where do we start yeah well look i mean
it's it's a complicated business
right um ethics generally speaking
people
people have broad intuitions that
certain things are right or wrong and
uh it's clear that some of these things
seem to vary um
across cultures across upbringings um
but generally speaking everybody seems
to have some kind of intuition that
there is such thing as right or wrong
when you when you break down ethics
there are a number of layers in which
you can look at it so
one of the most important distinctions
is between what might be called
practical ethics and what might be
called meta ethics
um the simplest way to define these two
is to say that
practical ethics is answers the question
of
what is good whereas meta ethics answers
the question of what good
is right so if you're talking about
practical ethics this is generally what
people think of when they think of
ethics right like
uh is abortion moral is euthanasia
permission permissible
um these kinds of questions questions of
veganism that kind of stuff social
justice any of that
um but underlying that we need to have
some understanding of
the meaning of the words we're using i
mean what does it actually mean to say
something is good
what does it mean to say that you ought
to do something like what are the
definitions of these terms
and this is what you call matter ethics
and this is the more difficult part in
my view
um and it's the part that like kind of
there seems to be
the most kind of irresolvable
disagreements because if you just have a
different intuition about what good is
um then you're kind of talking past each
other whereas if you can at least agree
that say you think that good
is good consists in what maximizes
well-being for conscious creatures
then when you have an argument about
veganism it becomes
essentially an objective discussion
because you can just objectively point
to
what affects well-being in various ways
but if you disagree about what it
actually means
um then you run into problems right
the thing is like nobody nobody seems to
agree on this right this isn't like a
scientific endeavor where you
you conduct a bunch of experiments and
you do peer review and then you just
figure out what the answer is it's like
we're asking the same questions that
aristotle and plato were asking you know
like not much has actually changed
uh and a lot of the time it's useful to
read those classics because a lot of
people
end up reinventing the wheel and doing
it badly because they're kind of
thinking about ethics and they have this
bright idea or anything this is amazing
um but it turns out you know 100 other
people have done it before them
but it's so buried in the literature
that they don't know it exists so it's
really worth kind of familiarizing
yourself with some of the
at least the basic kind of conceptions
of ethics across the board before you
can
jump into talking about practical ethics
um
but i i don't know like the
the kind of most uh interesting
distinction that people tend to start
with is
what ethics is kind of what ethics is
kind of driving at right i mean so for
instance
if i ask you what you think it means to
say something is good
what what does that i mean what do you
accomplish your intuition what do you
think that really means
leaving the situation with
more well-being or less suffering than
when you found it
sure so the question trivially just
becomes why should you care about
well-being why does that matter why
shouldn't we try to maximize suffering
there is a preference in one way
and that tends towards something which
is
not painful okay but what if someone
comes along and says look i
i prefer other people to suffer i don't
want myself to suffer but i think
you know i'm a i'm a i'm a sadist and i
really enjoy other people's sufferings i
think the best thing to do
is to cause as much suffering to them as
possible whilst minimizing my own
suffering presuming that we're all
sovereign wills
the preference of one shouldn't
influence the preference of another
right so now the question becomes why
right because
you can say something like look
generally there's a preference towards
this thing or the other but just because
the majority of people prefer something
that doesn't mean it's
necessarily the right thing to do okay
and the first question that this
highlights
is objectivity and ethics right one of
the most important distinctions to make
is between
a conception of objective ethics and a
conception of subjective ethics
to say that something is objectively
right or objectively moral say that
objective ethics exists is to say that
ethical propositions are true
regardless of what people think about
them right it doesn't matter what your
opinion is in other words because
you say something like well it could be
to do with like a preference for
well-being but
if everybody on planet earth decided
that you know the holocaust was the
right thing to do
right let's say the holocaust wiped out
all of its opposition and germany win
the war and everybody or at least the
majority
on planet earth are convinced that that
was a good thing to do most people want
to say that that doesn't matter it was
still bad
it was still wrong even if everybody
doesn't agree with that right something
universal that sits outside of what an
individual's sense of is
right um now of course that leads us to
the intuition that morality does have at
least some objectivity right that
they're there
that you can say that an ethical
proposition is actually true
or false right and it doesn't matter
what you think about it
the problem then becomes grounding it
right like on whose authority is it good
or bad
now traditionally this is where religion
would step up to the mark and still
tries to today
and in fact a popular argument for the
existence of god
is the moral argument and the moral
argument is really simple and it says
if uh if god does not exist objective
morality
does not exist objective morality does
exist
therefore god exists right the idea
being that
if there is such thing as objective
morality it needs to be grounded in
something and it can only really be
grounded in some kind of
authority right it can't be grounded in
some kind of uh
preference of a human being or some kind
of naturalistic feature it has to have
some kind of authority behind it and
that can only really come from
a kind of supernatural authority that
supersedes everybody else right and so
it's basically
saying that because objective morality
exists god must exist
and there are multiple ways to respond
to this the first is to try to
ground objective morality in something
else but the second thing you can do
before we get too far ahead of ourselves
is to just say that morality actually
isn't objective right you could say that
morality is subjective that is it does
it it is dependent on what the person
feels um
now of course the biggest problem with
this is that you you run into the kind
of situations where somebody might say
well in my subjective opinion
the holocaust was a good thing um
therefore
it was the right thing to do right and
and this doesn't sit right with us but
there are kind of different levels that
subjectivity can work right so let me
give you one example
um of the the utilitarian case um
utilitarianism is broadly
an objective uh ethical theory but
but i'll give you a kind of form of it
that could demonstrate how the objective
and the subjective can can come together
so
i might say something like uh
i subjectively value my well-being
and so do you you you subjectively value
your well-being
and everybody subjectively values their
well-being now
it's trivially true that you you have to
value
your own pleasure you have to think it's
a good thing right some people
take pleasure in things that other
people find painful but that would
not that would just be a wrong
definition of pain for them because for
them that would be a pleasurable
experience or at least
it would lead to a pleasurable
experience now i can say something like
look
the the preference for pleasure is
subjective
right it's it's just it's just you to to
to your
uh to your preference right but there
are objective things we can know about
how to maximize it
so if i was a utilitarian who thought
that the basic justification for having
pleasure and well-being and suffering as
the the basis on which we ground ethics
i could say that that's subjective but i
could then be
objectivist in in my ways of kind of
analyzing situations and seeing what
would actually maximize pleasure
right so it can get a bit complicated
right and it's like
this this isn't even kind of this this
isn't even the beginning um
but like one of the best ways oftentimes
to
explore different ethical theories and
one of the ways in which people like to
write about it in in
in the academy is essentially to rely on
intuition right because you come up with
some kind of ethical theory and you need
to you need a way to test it
so you have your ethical theory and then
you run it against some kind of counter
example
and you say well this ethical theory
leads us to this conclusion which seems
so absurd
that we have to reject the ethical
theory and this is a lot of the time how
ethics
is done right in order to show why
someone's ethical theory is wrong
you show what it leads to and show that
it's that it's an absurdity or an
immorality or something that's so
obviously bad
that we have to throw out the the the
theory this is known as a reductio ad
absurdum
um and that's the best way to explore
ethics but like
jumping into the question of ethics it's
like it depends on what you want to do
it depends on
if you want to know what good is it
depends on if you want to sort of work
out famous moral dilemmas it depends on
if you if you're just trying to
look at a specific um moral issue and
trying to kind of break it down
like it depends what you want to do
right like in a conversation like this
there are so many avenues you can go
down
i understand is it possible to have a
conversation about practical ethics
with the conversation about meta ethics
still being poorly defined
it seems a little bit like playing
football but some people think you're
allowed to handle the ball and other
people think you can only kick it
yeah well that's exactly the problem if
you don't have the same metro theory
it's like you could be playing chess
with someone who's using the rules of
rugby and it's just it's not going to
work right
but generally speaking people do have
certain base level intuitions that are
roughly the same right and
you can talk about practical ethics
without breaking it into meta ethics and
i think it's more interesting to do so
um because meta ethics can get it can
get complicated and tricky and you have
to
define the difference between doing and
allowing and you have to
it gets it gets complicated i imagine it
gets quite semantic
as well that you just really a lot of
the time it's
what does this word mean and then you
get into sort of senses of etymology and
and sort of bizarre
um it's just linguistic territory this i
think is one of the
big challenges we have with
communication sort of generally at the
moment in the media
that no one's actually defining what
words mean we words can mean multiple
things there's a term called semantic
overload to learn from
ben shapiro and that is what's being
used an awful lot at the moment semantic
overload yeah
so imagine when you're having a very
complex discussion really
trying to get into the weeds with
something and work out the nuance of
practical ethics and then someone comes
in and goes well i know that you said
that you kicked the ball but is it
really a ball and why is it called ball
and you're like oh [ __ ] l mate come
on
exactly right i ruined the game this is
this is what you run into especially if
you talk to someone who's got an
interest in philosophy or ethics if you
talk to them on a practical level and
you say well look
i think that you know the mass
confinement and torture of animals is
is immoral for the purpose of you know a
fancy stake right and someone turns
around
if you talk to the average person
they'll talk around they'll turn around
and say what if they're treated this way
what if they're treated that way they
bring up practical concerns but an
ethicist might say well
wha why like why should i care about
animals suffering
like what does that matter now i could
say well care about animal suffering for
the same reason you care about human
suffering and they say
why should i care about human suffering
yeah and the question can go on and on
and on and on and on and you never kind
of come to a to a
useful stopping point unless you can
agree on something um but you can talk
about practical ethics without breaking
it down to meta ethics if you do have
certain
uh if you do have certain level
agreements so if i agree that we
shouldn't cause harm to
human beings unnecessarily and so do you
then i can make an argument from
consistency i can say that well
i think you're holding an inconsistent
set of beliefs if you're
okay with harming a human being oh
you're okay with harming a non-human
animal but you're not okay with harming
a human being it's like what are your
reasons
for one and the other and i could show
that maybe there's an inconsistency
there right
but like you could be consistently wrong
right like
i could we could make our ethical
practical ethical case completely
consistent i could say that
well in order to be uh against animal
exploitation you also have to be
i don't know you have to be pro-life in
this instance in that instance and
for some strange reason you also have to
hold this other belief and this other
belief in this other belief
and you can kind of convince someone of
all of those things but like
they could just be they could just have
a consistent worldview that's that's
wrong at its basis
right so it depends what you're trying
to do if you're trying to convince
someone of a moral cause then it's
better to talk on the practical level
and try to point out inconsistencies but
if you're trying to get to the question
of what is actually
good uh then you're better off
talking a bit about matter ethics and
one of the most important questions
is what is the focus of ethics does does
the focus of ethics
which let's say does ethics should
ethics focus
on say the consequence of an action
should it focus on the action itself
should it focus on the agent performing
the action right these three are broadly
three ways in which people distinguish
ethics so if we consider a statement
like murder is wrong
some people might analyze that to mean
that murder is wrong because the
consequences that it leads to that is
you know someone dying
people suffering people mourning are bad
right and so generally speaking in order
to determine whether something's right
or wrong we look at the consequences of
the action
seems somewhat intuitive but some people
like to
instead say that the focus of ethics
should be and this is consequentialism
sometimes called teleology from the
greek word telos for
end or purpose um some people prefer to
look at the agent they prefer to say
that
don't the reason you shouldn't murder is
because
the virtuous person wouldn't murder
right like murder
is not a virtuous thing to do
aristotle's ethics
was a virtue ethics theory and it was
kind of like the right thing to do is
what the virtuous person would do
in other words so it's not so much about
the action or its consequences it's
about
it's it's about the person committing
the action right um some people prefer
to just look at the action itself not
the consequence but the action itself
they say murder is wrong
in and of itself regardless of the
consequences regardless of who's
performing it
um and this generally comes from this
this is a kind of typical view of
religious people a lot of the time with
divine command theory who think that
ethics is just what's commanded by god
so if god says don't murder then
don't murder that that's that's kind of
it full stop doesn't matter what
consequences are
it's just wrong in and of itself and all
of these things have
kind of weight to them and the reason
why why people like kind of flip back
and forth
in them when they're studying them is
because each of them seem to have kind
of difficult ethical territory
like if you i think most people are at
the beginning tend to be more
uh attracted to consequentialist ethics
um that's because i think that
generally speaking our society is is has
is a bit more based on consequentialist
ethics than anything else like in
in the modern era that seems to be kind
of the implicit way that people do
ethics
but there are some really kind of
uh difficult problems with that so for
instance let me take your
uh let me take your proposition that
kind of the right thing to do is what
maximizes well-being
right so this would be a
consequentialist view and essentially a
utilitarian one
um utilitarianism being the idea that we
should maximize utility
and utilitarians identify utility
utility with pleasure so essentially the
the best thing to do
is to maximize pleasure or minimize
suffering now
there are there are various problems
with this but let me give you one
example
uh this comes from a guy called roger
crisp who's a kind of leading
john stuart mill scholar and every
undergraduate at oxford has to read
his commentary on on uh utilitarianism
and he gives this example of the rash
doctor right so let me ask you a
question here
a doctor has a patient and they've got
two potential medicines that they can
give to the patient okay like
option a and option b uh option a
has option a if successful will restore
the patient
to a hundred percent health but it's got
a 99 chance of failure
and only a one percent chance of working
the 99 chance is that they'll die right
so 99 chance this is just going to kill
the patient
only one percent chance is going to
succeed but if it does it's going to
restore them fully to health
option b it will only restore them to
say 85 percent health but it's got a 99
chance
of being successful and only one percent
chance of the patient dying
right say the doctor chooses option a
and it works did the doctor do the right
thing
[Laughter]
to everyone who's listening i've already
warned you about this but i want you to
be playing along at home
as well because this difficulty the the
mental gears that you're going to be
able to hear in me that are whirring
away i want you to be suffering along
with me so
um from a consequentialist just the
outcome
does the end justify the means um i
suppose
in that form yes um
you could do that a million times and
keep on getting the one out of 100.
well so the difficult thing to say is
like intuitively when faced with the
option before we know what's actually
going to happen and you've got the two
the medicines in front of you like
you'd probably advise the doctor to take
option b yeah right you had a match
of course yeah and that seems that seems
justifiable right it seems like that
should be the case but
the weird conclusion is that if he uses
option b
and it works and the patients restore to
85 health
whether or not the doctor did the right
thing completely depends on what would
have happened
if he'd administer drug a because if
had he administered drug a it failed
then what the doctor did actually did
maximize
well-being right because it was 85
health versus death
whereas if it were the case that had he
gone for option a
it would have worked then what he's done
has actually not maximized
pleasure right because instead of
well-being let's say
uh because instead of 85 healthy could
get 100 health now
the kind of easy answer to this is to
say well
okay so it's not actually about you
shouldn't do what will actually maximize
pleasure
you should do what will probably
maximize pleasure
right but you can see we've already kind
of adapted the theory right we've
already gone from kind of saying well
obviously it's it's about kind of
what maximizes the right thing to do is
whatever's going to actually maximize
someone's well-being
but like that's not always the case
because there's a caveat
yeah even even if like in this situation
yeah had you done the other thing it
would have actually like in in reality
in the actual world would have caused
more
more pleasure it's like it probably
wasn't justified to do that right
so yeah now we're kind of talking about
probabilistic
utilitarianism right um does this
continue to roll
down so does probabilistic
utilitarianism then split into
some other subdivisions some other
subdivision well
it doesn't always divide kind of
subdivide in that manner but there are
there are lots of different kinds of
divisions so
i imagine there's just a tree branch
that continues to go down
my point is like for every situation
that you encounter do you then need to
continue to create
a um sub discipline within that that
allows you to explore that particular
type of solution
pretty much and and luckily because
these questions have been being asked
for thousands of years
you can find hundreds of essays on any
particular kind of individual
instance of a moral dilemma that you
have but like there's another there's a
further distinction that might be made
between what you could call uh what what
roger crisp at least calls
the criterion of good and the decision
procedure
right and these are two separate things
so the criterion of good
is that the criterion by which we
determine whether or something
whether or not something is good um
whereas the decision procedure
is the way that we try to go bringing
about that good right
so take this utilitarian analysis where
we've shown that you know you should act
in a way that probably maximizes
pleasure like that would be our decision
procedure like
we kind of decide intuitively that the
way to determine how we decide what to
do
should be based on probabilistic
utilitarianism right
but has it changed the actual criterion
of good if we offer a kind of abstract
analysis of what good
is well we don't think that good
is what would prob we don't think that
good is the result of what would
what you should probably do or something
like that we still think that the good
thing is what maximizes pleasure and
minimizes suffering
even if we've decided that the way we
decide which actual action we're going
to take is more probabilistic
so the criterion of good for
utilitarianism is still what is
actually most pleasurable but the
decision procedure
leads us to probabilistic utilitarianism
the route to get there now has some form
of discounting that's been through yeah
and it seems a bit strange like why is
it that we've got an ethical theory
where we've decided that this is what's
good but that's not what we should
actually do in order to
try and achieve that good right it seems
like an inconsistency
it seems a little a little strange right
further distinctions like
the classic kind of argument against
utilitarianism is is something like uh
an instance of a gang rape or something
it's like well don't don't the pleasure
of of the many
outweigh the suffering of the single
individual and some people would say
well no because the suffering is so
great that even five people
you know getting immense pleasure it's
not going to outweigh it but if if you
think that then just make it six people
or seven people or 100 people
until the the scales get balanced out
and some people would say something like
well clearly
it would still be wrong in all
circumstances right so can we really say
that the maximization of pleasure
is the criterion of good is how we
should determine what we're what we're
doing if we've got a situation where it
seems it doesn't matter
how much kind of the the scale of the
well-being tips one way or the other
like we still wouldn't
be in favor of this right um and it's
like
yeah you've now got to rethink things
right and this is why people prefer
sometimes a a
kind of action-based view of morality um
known as deontology right like the idea
that the thing is
is wrong in a in of itself right it's
not about the consequence
it's that gang rape is wrong it's not
wrong because of the suffering that it
will
bring about this person or something
like that it's just wrong right
and so when faced with an ethical
dilemma like that you've kind of got two
choices you either have to further
adapt or explain or analyze your
utilitarianism or maybe you have to
adopt deontology or maybe you have to
accept the conclusion that gang rape is
actually moral and that's the least
popular
line to go down funnily enough um
but so you know the the utilitarian
might say
okay well look i mean it's it's not
about what will maximize pleasure in any
given
instance but let's say you know uh the
best thing to do
is to act according with a general rule
which if followed broadly would maximize
pleasure
right so even if in that individual
instance you know
it would maximize pleasure to allow
people to to commit horrible crimes like
if we allowed everybody to live by that
rule suffering would rise overall
because of people being scared of being
accosted on the street and people being
scared of being robbed or raped whatever
it may be so
okay so so it now becomes look the thing
that we should do
is act in accordance with rules which if
generally
abided by would maximize pleasure
okay so now our decision procedure has
kind of morphed into
you shouldn't do what always maximizes
pleasure you shouldn't even do what
always
probably maximizes play you should do
what what
would probably maximize pleasure if we
made it a rule that everyone followed
it's like
we're getting a lot more kind of further
detached we're down the tree
we're down this little tree and you
notice the way that we've done that
is simply by taking the ethical theory
that we started with that you kind of
just kind of hypothesized at the
beginning and just said
but that leads to this okay so we should
adapt it in this way but then that leads
to this and that leads to this and that
leads to this right
and like yeah these things kind of come
out of nowhere like a lot of the time
someone will come up with an idea that
just says like
like what about this counter example um
and
it just it just kind of blows everyone
away and everything has to be
rethought that happened in the uh in the
philosophy of knowledge
um because one of the one of the most
interesting things about philosophy to
me is that
nobody has a sufficient analysis really
of what knowledge is
no one can really decide on what what
constitutes knowledge
um and the reason for that is because
well let's let's think about what not
i mean okay let me let me just ask you
just out of interest like what do you
think if
you had to give like a definition of
knowledge what would it be like how can
you say that you know something is true
that sounds like two questions knowing
that something is true versus knowing
things
well i need to say like what's the
definition of knowledge in either case
what does it mean to know something
an accumulation of understanding about
the world
okay so so uh basically you now holding
a belief
about the world which is represented
accurately in reality
okay so which is actually true right so
you holding a belief about the world
which is true
that was that far off as someone else
said that someone's
honest well you can you can test it
right because you could say something
like if somebody
was in a room with no windows
and irrationally they just believed it
was raining
but it was raining did they know that it
was raining
because they believe that it's raining
and it's true that it's raining but do
they know that it's raining
well clearly not okay so so it can't
just be
kind of having a belief that's true that
can't be knowledge because you can
accidentally hold a true belief
so then the definition the popular
definition became justified true belief
and you'll hear this phrase thrown
around all the time it's like well you
have to you have to believe something is
true
it has to be true and you have to be
justified in believing that it's true
what do they mean by justified
and then you have to you have to believe
that it's true for good reasons and
people will offer different analyses of
what what is a good reason and what's
not but like so they'll say for instance
just just kind of imagining that it's
raining outside isn't a good reason but
if you look out of the window and you
see that it's raining that's good reason
to believe that it's
that it's raining and so if you look out
the window you see that it's raining
then you believe that it's raining it is
actually raining and you're justified in
that belief so you know that it's
raining
voila problem solved right
enter edmund get here who
just kind of blew the lid off everything
and as far as i'm as far as i recall
being being told this he kind of he he
he wrote this kind of somewhat
flippantly like he he was going through
like different problems that that seemed
to just be kind of
put to bed and just for the hell of it
was just seeing if he could come up with
counter examples
and he wrote this really really short
paper it's like two pages long and it
just blew up the philosophy of knowledge
right
got rid of this idea of justified true
belief now i'll tell it to you now right
yeah this is
kind of crazy this sounds a little bit
like
you know around about springtime when
you finally got rid of all of the [ __ ]
old clothes that you don't need anymore
and you've got them all they're all in
the charity shop your mum's taking them
to oxfam in those big sort of
see-through bags
and um and you and you're like right all
my socks are back in these are only the
socks that i wear
all the drawers are organized color
coded size everything else
and someone's just come in and gone just
grabbed all of your stuff and then just
throwing it around the room
yeah it it it's also sometimes a bit
like someone's kind of
as as your mom is driving away with all
of the clothes in the bag someone looks
and goes
you know that she's taken this with her
and you have to go oh run after it
because you realize that what you've
said yeah what you've said has actually
taken away this really important belief
of yours right because you
you're like i think this is this is the
right theory this is the right way to go
and someone says
yeah but you know that if you if you do
that then this other belief you hold has
to fly out the window and you're like oh
crap and you're running after it as fast
as you can right yeah okay so
and this kind of this kind of happened
with knowledge right
and such such cases as he presented in
this paper are known now as gettier
cases
um which essentially a gettier case is
an
instance of justified true belief that
is not knowledge
because again we're working with counter
examples here so if if the theory is
that while knowledge is justified true
belief then if you can offer an example
of someone having justified true belief
that isn't knowledge
then we have to throw out that theory
and we have to come up with something
better so
get here says imagine and i need to make
sure it's been a while since i've
since i want to make sure i get this
right imagine somebody is
waiting for they're in a job interview
there are two guys in a job interview
and uh while they're waiting to hear
back from the from the interviewer
the uh the person who he's across from
is getting bored and he decides
to take the coins that he's got in his
pocket out and starts counting them on
the table because he's bored
and he sees him counting 10 coins right
so he he knows that this guy's got
10 coins in his pocket um
then what happens is the interviewer
comes out and basically says
listen you know i haven't spoken to the
board yet but but it seems like you're
going to get the job right like
we're pretty sure you're gonna get the
job um
which uh oh sorry he we're pretty sure
the other guy's gonna get the job the
guy who was counting the coins i said
we're pretty sure this guy's gonna get
the job
and uh this kind of gives you a
justified belief
that this man is going to get the job
but
one thing that you know although you
could say that you know maybe you have a
justified belief that this man is going
to get the job
another thing that you have to justify
belief and by derivative is you have a
justified belief
that the person who will get the job has
10 coins in his pocket
because you've seen this guy counting
out 10 coins and you've got a justified
reason to think that he's gonna
that he's going to um to get the job
and so you have a justified belief that
this person
that the person who gets the job is
going to have 10 coins in his pockets
now something goes wrong something like
really unexpected something unlikely
right so this this
it's not fair to say that you could have
predicted this but something something
happens
and as it turns out you end up getting
the job it's you not the other guy you
get the job
and you think oh this is great i've got
the job but just as it happens
you happen to have 10 coins in your
pocket just by chance you've also got 10
coins in your pocket
so your belief you had a justified true
belief that the person who gets the job
would have 10 coins in his pocket
but it seems it seems like you can't say
that you knew that
because as it turns out like yeah i
guess it was true that the person who
got the job had 10 coins in his pocket
and i guess you were justified in
believing that
but like surely that's not knowledge
because clearly you kind of meant
something else right like
that can't be knowledge but this is an
instance of justified true belief and
this actually happened to me once in
in person because there are all kinds of
gettier cases that you can you can
construct
um and that's kind of a clumsier one to
understand perhaps but this happened to
me once
um i was i was in a car and i was
driving around a big corner right
and so i saw this this child
um kind of above the hedge like around
the corner kind of
bobbing up and down and i looked over
there and i thought she was riding a
horse
so as we're going around the corner i
think oh man like that there's a horse
over there that's that's quite quite
excited to see this horse right
so turn around the corner and turns out
she's not on a horse she's walking
she's on like her dad's back right but
just by chance there also happens to be
a horse
in the field now i kid you not this
actually happened to me and i sat there
and i thought to myself
this is a guessier case because like
although you know maybe i wasn't
entirely justified in believing that the
girl was on a horse
like seeing a horse that high up bobbing
along i think you know
i could form a justified belief that she
was riding a horse um
and the belief was that there's a horse
there so i believed that a horse was
there it was true that a horse was there
and i was justified in believing that a
horse was there
but did i know that the horse was there
like can you really say that i knew it
before
do you see what i'm saying like this
doesn't seem to count as knowledge right
and so guess here kind of is talking
about these cases and people are like
damn so now we have to now i have to
change it up
and it just got off with the socks yeah
yeah it just it it just kind of
completely upends everything that we
think about the analysis of knowledge
and this is what happens in ethics
all the time some bastard comes in
with a cricket bat and breaks everything
exactly um but sometimes it can also
work in people's favor right so an
example would be with
an analysis of free will i'm someone who
doesn't believe that free will exists or
otherwise say i have an active belief
that free will does not exist
um why do you have that distinction uh
because
it's one thing to be just unconvinced of
something it's another thing to believe
that it's false right so like
uh let me put it this way versus atheist
pretty much yeah but it's i would say
that agnosticism is a
claim to knowledge whereas theism is a
claim to belief um so i'd characterize
it like this
this comes from my friend matt
dillahunty if i had a random jar of
of don't have anything i can use right
now um
and you didn't know how many coins were
in the jar
and neither did i and i said look i
think there's an even number of coins in
this jar
would you believe me no
but that doesn't mean you believe it's
false right no
i just i don't don't don't agree yeah i
think this is the distinction
there's a distinction between not
believing a proposition
and believing that the proposition is
false so if you believe that i was if
you believe that it was false that means
you believe there's an odd number
if you just don't believe that it's true
that means that you're kind of reserving
judgment so
some people might say i don't believe in
free will that is i'm reserving judgment
i don't know i i'm not convinced that
free will exists i'm saying i'm
convinced free will does not exist
but and that's a whole another podcast
but this has interesting implications
for ethics because there's this common
intuition that in order to be held
responsible for something
you need to have freely chosen to do it
it's like you can't be held responsible
for something you didn't
freely choose to do right this is a
general intuition that people
uh the people held uh for the longest
time
which seems to make a lot of sense it's
like how can you hold someone
responsible if they if they can't have
acted otherwise can you hold them
morally responsible
and so if there's no free will basically
nobody's ever responsible for anything
they do because
is there any morality left well exactly
this is this is the big problem it's
like
where does morality go um but then again
people were coming up with counter
examples um so generally speaking
the idea is that the principle could be
kind of summed up as
you can't be held morally responsible if
it's the case that you couldn't have
acted otherwise
so if you were a passenger on a train
and a train kills a person it's not your
fault that the train killed the person
you didn't get to control the train yeah
but also uh it might be something like
if you trip over by mistake and you
knock someone in front of a train and
they get hit by a train
that's not really your fault because
it's an accident you fell over and
that's different from pushing them
potentially but if you if you tripped
through no fault of your own or if
someone else pushed you and you
you ended up pushing into them it's like
you're not morally responsible because
you couldn't have acted otherwise and
it's based on
intent it seems like that appears to be
the distinction
yes um i suppose so uh
actually no it might not be because
there's some constraints you're saying
couldn't have acted otherwise so you
might not have intended to do something
but you could have acted otherwise
yeah this is the manslaughter versus
murder versus accidental death
yeah pretty much um but then it also
gets more complicated
um of course it does is there anything
that doesn't
ah man veganism is quite simple
everyone that's playing vegan bingo at
home that's three times today yeah
yeah how do you know if someone's vegan
you know that's the the
like that kind of gets on my nerves it's
like um oh how do you know someone's got
a nut allergy don't worry they'll tell
you it's like yeah
of course i'm gonna bloody tell you so
i'm going for a meal with you and i'm
yeah okay so uh intent what's this
thought experiment
so uh harry frankfurt comes along and
and
basically the job is to to disprove this
intuition is you've got to come up with
a situation in which someone couldn't
have acted otherwise
and yet is still morally responsible for
their action
right which seems like a hard task uh
one example that peter vanning in wagon
has
given is of somebody who witnesses a
crime
and decides not to call the police
immorally so i should call the police
but decides not to right feeling about
evil or something you know
doesn't want the person to see justice
but this person doesn't know that the
phone lines were down anyway
so even if he tried to phone the police
he couldn't have phoned the police so
this person did not call the police but
he couldn't have acted otherwise because
he couldn't have phoned the police
but we still hold him morally
responsible even though he couldn't have
acted otherwise
that's a good example now somebody might
say something like yeah but look i mean
clearly what matters here is like the
intention right it's it's the it's the
intent it's kind of the person so
because he still could have tried to
call the police
and then the phone lines would have been
down but like
harry frankfurt discusses loads and
loads of very particular
cases but one of the one of the examples
you could potentially give is that
you've got somebody who is like a
neuroscientist
and is able to like kind of is hooked up
to your brain in such a way that he can
kind of prod your brain and make you do
certain things and change your mental
states
and he basically says um you know let's
say you're you're voting in a
in an election or something and one of
the candidates is
some kind of genuine tyrant and it's
like it would be immoral to vote for
this person and
the the neuroscientist essentially kind
of
scans your brain and sees that if you're
going to vote for the
for the person of your own accord he
just lets you do it
right but if he realizes from your brain
activity that you're about to go and
vote for the other person
he will kind of fiddle about with your
brain in such a way that you become
motivated to go
and and vote for the other person so you
know let's say that you
you go to vote for the good party and
this person kind of
hooks up to your brain and changes your
motivations and makes you want to go and
do this thing you'd say that person's
not responsible for voting for the bad
person because it's not their fault that
the person was
was in their brain but like what if the
person goes and votes for the bad person
of their own accord
because like clearly they're morally
responsible because they they've freely
chosen of their own accord
to go and vote for this this bad
tyrant right but they couldn't have
acted otherwise because have they tried
to vote for the other one they would
have been motivated to vote for him
anyway so it's like
can we really say they're morally
responsible well intuitively we want to
say yeah they're still morally
responsible
but if you're morally responsible
despite the fact
that you couldn't have acted differently
you couldn't have even wanted
differently
then we seem to have a counter example
to the case or to the proposition that
you know you can only be held
responsible if you couldn't if you could
have acted otherwise right
um and again like this leads to a wealth
of discussion and there are lots of
different responses to this
like i've i've got my responses to it
other people have their responses to it
uh and i think there's like satisfactory
responses to this but at the very least
you can see that it's not as simple as
people originally thought right because
you
the great thing about ethics is you can
come up with incredibly contrived
thought experiments you can come up with
the most ridiculous scenarios in the
world and someone can say that's the
most unrealistic thing i've ever heard
but it doesn't matter because if it
contradicts your theory then it means
the theory is wrong it doesn't matter
how
how crazy the thought experiment has to
be it's kind of like when people are
talking about utilitarianism and they
say
okay but what if we painlessly kill
somebody right
and they suffer no pain someone says
well that's still bad because people
around them would suffer
they say okay well what if you know what
if we
kill somebody who's like homeless and
has no family and no one cares about
them
we say okay yeah but that's still wrong
because someone has to do the killing
and that and kind of
that that might kind of affect them and
say okay okay so what if we like what if
we like are in a cabin in the woods
and we painlessly kill someone and the
person who does the killing like
immediately forgets
and the person who makes them forget
doesn't know why they're making
and it's like it's getting a bit it's
getting a bit contrived it's getting a
bit crazy but
the thing is like if in that situation
you've still got a counter example if if
the if the counter example is like
logically coherent as far-fetched as it
may be
it can still expose the flaw in the
ethical thinking right
the battleground the battleground of
ethics is um
really fast-moving i'm guessing based on
that like
you think about science you have to
construct an experiment
perhaps even get some funding put some
pants on leave the house
do the actual thing analyze the data
whereas all you really need to do here
is like have an armchair and a brain and
and you can one of the great things
about ethics is you can do it all by
yourself and you don't need any
funding for it but at the same time it's
also very slow moving because
the basic questions have been the same
questions for thousands of years it's
just like somebody will come up with an
interesting particular thought
experiment that requires
various different responses or a thought
experiment that ends up having
quite impactful uh or quite an impact in
the rest of philosophy or something like
that but like
the fundamental question of the basis
hasn't hasn't really changed like
modern developments can inform our
ethical discussions but they don't
really change the nature of them
you know for example when you develop
technology you can start talking about
living in a simulation and this kind of
stuff but like
the question is still the same so the
thought experiment might be like the
experience machine of hooking someone up
to the matrix where they experience more
pleasure but it's not real
um yeah sure that's kind of that's a new
thought but
the idea of kind of somehow
replicating uh reality is not new
you know like we've just moved from
descartes evil demon that that makes you
think you're living in a particular
world
to it being done by the matrix right so
like particular thought experiments and
the way that they're expressed can can
change quickly
um but the fundamental questions are
still the same
has it been has it been quite a while
since anything
revolutionary in terms of a question to
be asked as opposed to a criticism of an
existing question has come up
i mean you you'll tend to kind of tend
to know when that happens because
this is this is what can make people
famous when they come up with a way of
kind of putting things together
um a lot of people consider like the
kind of most recent really important
person to have been someone like
emmanuel kant
um like the thing is like
it's difficult because it's it's so kind
of uh it's so abstract right
like it's difficult to determine whether
what someone's saying is actually new or
if it's just a synthesis of
previous ideas or something like that um
but generally speaking the progress is
slow
right like the the big steps that are
taken in ethics will be like on a very
very particular question on a very very
particular
point of ethics like if somebody manages
to prove somehow philosophically that
we're
not living in a simulated reality that
would be a really important and
uh kind of philosophical discovery of
how we'd managed to argue that
um that would have wide reaching
implications right for instance if
someone kind of discovered
it just so happens that i've got a
philosophical argument that says that we
can't replicate consciousness because
you know the simulation argument of nick
bostrom
says that you know humanity will get to
the point where it can simulate human
consciousness
and that consciousness will be able to
simulate consciousness and so on and so
on and so on and the likelihood that you
happen to be in base reality is
is minimal it's tiny did you watch the
episode of joe rogan where nick
tries to explain that to him uh i i
didn't but
we've talked about that yeah i brought
it up anyone that's listening
you'll have heard me talk about super
intelligence a number of times one of my
favorite books
recently read the precipice by toby ord
who i texted you about
and said is he one of your uh lecturers
at uni uh the press piece about
existential rescues from the same future
of humanity institute
nick bostrom guy that i've read for tons
and tons of time sits down with my
favorite podcaster joe rogan i think
[ __ ] hell this is great
it's gonna be brilliant um joe simply
does not get the simulation hypothesis
which is like nick's sort of
at least one of nick's crowning works um
and he's
fairly straightforward to understand and
then for 45 minutes
continues to force the audience down the
same groundhog
sort of yeah exchange um so yeah if you
want to find out about nick bostrom do
not watch his episode
with joe rogan unless you want to tear
your eardrums out
um so yes uh yeah you can just read the
paper that he put out um
precisely there's one interesting thing
i was thinking there that
the discovery of knowledge
in philosophy or ethics
where does that come from or what is
that discovery because it's not like we
have discovered a new star this is a
particular new type of
element this is a new proton it's
somehow
universal and existent
and yet is also manifest by
someone's thoughts and also quite sort
of transient and ephemeral
i think you can think of it in the same
way this this is probably the most
helpful way to think of it
potentially is to think about it in
terms of like mathematical uh
discoveries
because you know maths is kind of a
language that we invent to describe
things that we believe are analytically
true
um and it's essentially tautologies you
know to say that one plus one equals two
is kind of the same as just saying two
is two
um but you can make mathematical
discoveries because people kind of have
they put together equations and i'm not
a mathematician but you know like
you can kind of make discoveries by
putting different propositions together
and seeing and seeing how they work
right
um and it's weird to think that you can
kind of discover things in this manner
in this kind of weird abstract kind of
sense but like i think the same thing is
roughly going on like
ethical movements are made when people
kind of
realize implications of beliefs we
already hold or realize a new way of
justifying them or something like that
or realize an inconsistency that we that
we hold
um most of the kind of most of the kind
of effort
when you say something like ethical
progression people tend to think of like
in practice they tend to think of things
like
uh slavery being abolished or or the
vegan movement
that's number four uh and like yeah sure
but that
there are two different things we could
be talking about because there's that
kind of ethical progression
um which is where we we like to think oh
well we're we're practically changing to
live
up to like the objective ethical
standard that we've
constructed or that exists or however
you want to frame it
um but another question is like what
about the frame itself like
can we kind of have a development in
that frame and sometimes the development
in the frame leads to developments and
practice but
this is this is one of the questions
that will help you determine whether you
think objective morality exists it's
like do we discover ethical truths or do
we invent them
do we do we kind of come across
objective truths about the way we should
behave or do we just kind of
decide uh on on a new way of living uh
to be consistent with our preferences or
something like that like
that's that's one of the most
fundamental questions to figure out
whether object
whether ethics actually objectively
exists um
is that the question that jordan
peterson and sam harris
got a little bogged down with
during the live debate i think
potentially
um because they they would both i'm not
as familiar with jordan peterson's um
sam harris's morality but i think both
believe in objective morality but they
have different justifications for it
and sam harris's is just it's trash i
mean it's it's awful it's just it it
doesn't make any sense um
uh and i think jordan peterson was kind
of trying to poke holes in it because
sam harris kind of says well well-being
should be the basis of morality um
because we all care about well-being and
someone says
yeah but like why is well-being good why
is suffering bad and
sam harris says well if you don't
believe me you're gonna put your hand on
a hot stove
and it's like dude you're missing you're
really missing the point here it's not
like
i don't doubt that i wouldn't like
putting my hand on a hot stove but why
does that make it objectively wrong
like because for it to be objectively
wrong it would be kind of
wrong regardless of what i think about
it doesn't matter if i prefer it or not
it's like
it's wrong of its own accord somehow if
no human beings existed
it would still be wrong to inflict
suffering even if there's no one to
affect the suffering upon something like
that like
and sam harris kind of doesn't doesn't
address that and i think jordan peterson
kind of pokes tries to put holes in that
yeah yeah
but he's broken holes in the
justification not not the idea that
ethics is objective
did you see i'm going to guess that you
probably won't have done because you
know on social media as much as me
but sam is releasing a making sense
book which is a synthesis of things he's
spoken about on the podcast he's doing
it tim ferriss
did you see it i didn't see that it's
come out today so it got announced
everybody pre-order available today
um uh so yeah it's just the tim ferriss
model man
have a conversation write a book about
the conversations
then have a conversation about the book
that you wrote about the conversations
and then yeah just continue to keep on
going you monetize so okay man let's
let's
let's have some of your favorite uh
thought experiments that we
might have not uh might have not covered
yet anything that sort of uh
you think is is gonna bend people's
minds a little bit as they try and
answer it
well ethically speaking i mean okay so i
remember when we um
when you asked me to come on i i wasn't
sure if you wanted to talk more about
meta ethics or if you wanted to because
you said you want to just go through
some like
ethical dilemmas so like there are a few
that you can that you can think of and
and
there are different ways in which
they're difficult so for instance um
consider the fact that this would be
this would be a demonstration that
sometimes
the consequences of a certain thing that
we think is good are actually that they
have unexpected consequences
so broadly speaking we think that it's
good to educate people the more educated
people are the better
but education rate is directly
correlated to suicide rate right the
more educated the society becomes the
higher the suicide rate
so is it actually immoral
to educate a society more if it's going
to lead to more suicidality
like do we are we placing a value on
knowledge itself do we not value
knowledge because of
what it does for humanity like and do we
have the right to essentially kind of
risk
a rise in suicide in order to educate
other people like
i don't know it's like you don't
necessarily think of that consequence
another example of like an unintended
consequence might be something like
i remember i went to a talk once about
um
uh the ethics of of
markets right what can be sold and what
can't so things like organ selling and
prostitution and sex work right
and i think broadly speaking in liberal
society people are in favor of sex work
they say look you
you are it's your body you can sell it
as you please like you should be able to
do that and
you know i was roughly in agreement but
i'm listening to this talk and i'm
thinking
okay so let's say we legalize
prostitution
there's a consequence that people don't
necessarily
think about right if you if you become
like a like a like a merchant
of sex um that's like a really good name
for a band
yeah or or a street name maybe um
we have we have laws that exist that say
that if you're a merchant if you're
selling a product
you don't get to discriminate who you
sell your product to
right now it's it's slightly different
with things like baking a cake that has
a certain message on it that was a big
controversy but that's because you're
kind of
you're producing a specific you know a
specific kind of designed to order thing
right it's not just a general
product that you're offering so the
person who baked that cake basically
said
i'm not gonna bake a cake that says like
happy marriage to a gay couple because
that goes against my beliefs but i can't
deny them service
to like a product that anybody else
could buy because they're gay so if they
came in and bought one of my pre-made
cakes
i can't then i service them and i
wouldn't do right now did they make that
distinction
uh yeah the the cake seller definitely
did so he actually had a fairly good
sort of
consistent grounding philosophy yeah he
said look like
it's not it's not about like i'm not
going to sell to a gay person that's not
what it is it's i'm not going to produce
like
essentially like a piece of celebration
of that in
the same way that like although you know
i wouldn't want to draw an equivalency
between these two
it works by analogy if someone came in
and said you know can you bake a cake
that says the n word on it or something
you'd be like i don't i don't want to
make that because it goes against my my
beliefs and someone could be like but
you're just you're discriminating
against me because you know because i'm
black and i'm watering a cake it's like
no it's like it's because of what you're
you're making me do
now obviously i'm not trying to say that
you know
that you should be as uncomfortable
writing the n word as saying happy happy
wedding to a gay couple but i'm saying
like
the kind of basic principle is that
there's a difference between refusing
someone service because of
who they are and refusing them service
because of what they're asking you to do
but if you're
selling sex just as a general product
like
we have laws that say that you can't
discriminate right you can't refuse
someone's service because they're gay or
because they're black or because they're
female or something
but you should be able to refuse sex at
any time for any reason
right like if you're having sex like in
the porn industry or something
like you should be able to you should be
allowed to determine
whether you have sex with men or not
right
you should be able to decide whether you
have sex with someone who's black or
white
or someone who you find attractive or
don't find attractive someone who's
disabled like it is your
is your basic right to determine who you
have sex with and who you don't
but if you're kind of selling a general
product of sex does that mean that you
kind of are forced to offer your
services to men as well as a woman like
if you became a prostitute chris could i
try and hire you and you say look i
don't
i don't serve men i could take you to
the supreme court and say well look
you're discriminating against me on the
basis of sex it's like
that's an interesting implication that
people don't generally think about
and i raised it with the guy giving the
talk and he kind of didn't really have
an answer for it because i don't think
it's a
particularly common objection to bring
up i know that i i discovered actually
after the fact that one of my tutors for
practical ethics had written a paper to
this
effect discussing this exact question of
like
like here's a kind of interesting reason
that maybe we shouldn't be in favor of
the legalization of prostitution and
it's not what you think it's not like oh
it's
it's lewd it's bad it's like it's like
you're gonna either have to create
something of like an entire new moral
legal category about denying people of
service on the basis of sex or
disability or
attractiveness i mean imagine refusing
someone of a service because you don't
think they're attractive like
this is this is brand new territory but
if you don't do that
then you're essentially saying this
person must be compelled to have sex
with anybody who wants it if they if
they pay the right price and that that
seems equally uncomfortable so
it's like maybe not as simple as your
first thought isn't it interesting
where we have
things that we're incredibly familiar
with that are
um artifacts of our
heritage as human beings like where
modes of thinking the the
um implicit assumption that you should
only have sex with people that you want
to have sex with
and yet at the same time when that comes
crashing into something that we also
know really really well which is
a more modern invention like free
markets and
inequality and equal treatment right
yeah and when when those two things sort
of come crashing together you're like uh
hang on
i'm i feel like i'm supporting both
teams here like how the [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] is this working
and people try to kind of people might
try to wriggle out of it or synthesize
and they might say something like well
if you agree to be a prostitute then
then you agree
to offer your services to anybody so
it's like
you know we're not just saying anybody
has to have sex with whoever asks it
is like if you enter into a contractual
agreement that says you're a prostitute
you now have to have sex with whoever
wants but it's like are you saying that
someone can like
sign off their consent are you saying
that someone could like sign a contract
which says
i am no longer able to consent in any of
my sexual encounters so long as the
person is paying it's like
i don't think that's what you want
either right it's like and maybe we
might think that
although every instinct says something
like well your body is your private
property and you should be able to you
should be able to sell it or you like
you should be able to do what you like
and make money with it as you like
we might think that we value our
principles of equality under the
under like the free market so so highly
that it's worth sacrificing this this
other
kind of principle that people should be
able to sell their bodies and we say
actually no
like we're not going to allow people to
sign away their consent and so we're not
going to legalize prostitution but
it's like every argument that you hear
in the popular discourse against
prostitution is like
it it it's wrong man it's like you
shouldn't man that's like
that's that could be your daughter man
it's like
it's kind of it hasn't got the right
focus right there are better arguments
that you could be making against
against the legalization of prostitution
that's that's for the benefit of
uh the person who'd be or the rights of
the person who's
selling it like it's a difficult
question it's worth you know your
listeners kind of just mulling it over
just thinking like what are the
implications of those kinds of beliefs
like
there are so many kind of hidden around
the corner that you might not be uh you
might not be
entirely aware of i agree man what else
you got anything else that you've got in
the tank that you've been uh
thinking here's one of my favorite
ethical dilemmas this is one of my
favorite ethical diamonds that was given
to me before i
came to university i was like i was like
16 17 i was in a pub
um and i met somebody who was studying
physics and philosophy at oxford
and it was first time i met him and he
just kind of
he's a bit of strange man he just turns
to me and says here's one for you
okay and this is always always a good
way to start isn't it this question
remained with me to this day right and i
want you to answer this honestly and
you know you might yeah you might be
kind of um exposing some immorality by
answering this honestly but i want you
to try your best
would you rather kill an innocent person
and then immediately forget about it or
not kill the innocent person but live
the rest of your life thinking that you
had
the second one you'd rather
not kill the person but live the rest of
your life thinking that you had
yeah probably because i haven't fully
thought through just how painful it
would be to believe that i would have
killed someone
right now so this is the this is the
answer that i think
people often give this answer at first
because it kind of sounds like the right
one to do
um and maybe you actually maybe would
actually be better for you um after
thinking about it for the longest
possible time the
the majority of people tend to kind of
say well actually i think i'd have to
say that i'd rather
kill the person than immediately forget
because like if you're talking about
like
i i i if as you say like
it's like you don't know what it's like
to live that life
believing that you've actually killed
that person but there are two different
questions
at on the table here the first is what
you would do in the second is what you
should do right
so like i think most people when they
think about it deeply enough realize
that because of the amount of sacrifice
that they're making
um they should they they would probably
kill the person and then forget because
they just can't deal with the with the
with the kind of backlash of that um but
that's a separate question from what
they
from what they should do and maybe they
shouldn't kill the innocent person but
you could also say like
you know should we expect somebody to
essentially sacrifice a life of
well-being for the life of another
person like do we have the right to
expect that of a person or do they have
a right to say that
you know if i don't commit this action
it's going to have this horrible
impingement on my
on the rest of my life and i actually
have a right to kind of look after my
own interests first
even if my own interests are kind of
lesser than another person's in the same
way that
if you uh decide not to give to charity
that's your right to do so
but like the the 25 pounds that you're
gonna save
is so much is worth so much less to you
than it would be worth
to people for whom you could buy
mosquito nets or something and save them
from getting malaria
um but we say that even though like
the the benefit that it gives you is is
much kind of is much less than the
benefit it would give the other person
like you have a right to look after
yourself first and look
and look to your interests first and
maybe you could say the same thing in
this instance uh i'm not entirely
sure um but it's a it's a difficult
question to think if you were really in
that situation what do you think you
would do
it's hard man i mean the
the question here and it seems like this
happens with a lot of it is whether or
not
you're able to take a third-party
perspective and the
the wood versus the should i.e the
armchair philosophy versus the actual
bratz brass roots action
those two things often i'm gonna guess
come into conflict with each other
because there isn't a third party
perspective
if we are talking about you doing the
thing there isn't a third party
perspective for you to take
there is only in the
should not the word right but if i mean
if morality is objective then we should
say like it doesn't matter what you
would do like
there's a there's a right answer to the
question regardless of what you you find
yourself actually doing
like in the famous trolley problem um
when you ask somebody whether they would
pull the lever and whether they'd push
the foot man off fat man off the bridge
you know the
the the famous take us through it so uh
you know
the trolley is is going down the track
and it's about to run into five
workers who are working on the track and
you can pull a lever
and it will divert the track the train
onto
a track that's got a single person
working so it'll kill one person instead
of the five and the question is
you know should you pull the lever or
would you pull the lever most people say
yeah of course i pull the lever i'm
going to
i'd rather you know the train goes into
one person than five people the
principle being yeah okay so
i'll sacrifice one person's life to save
five minutes in people's life fine
but then you ask the question what if
you're walking along and there's no
lever
and the train's going towards five
people on the track but there's this
really fat man walking across the bridge
and if you push him off the bridge he's
going to land on the train it's going to
kill him but he's going to stop the
train
would you push the fat man and people
are like
well i don't know i don't think so i
don't think i have the right to do that
hold on why not like
why is it that you're willing to kind of
pull a lever that kills
one person to say five people you're not
willing to push the man to kill the man
say that
five people and michael sandel who's um
a philosopher at harvard one of the most
famous philosophers living he's got a
great book by the way called justice
um which is a fantastic introduction to
ethics like i don't feel like i've done
a very good job here of like actually
going through the various ethical
theories who've just kind of been
mulling
here and there but if you want good
stuff if you want like a really good
introduction to just
what ethics is the different ways of
thinking about it justice by michael
sandel is a fantastic book and
in a lecture you can watch on youtube he
gives the trolley problem which is a
great starting point
for practical ethics it's one of the
first things that people will will talk
about and and he's talking to his
students and and he's asking
this question and the student kind of
says but you know i don't want to
it's different because there's a
difference between me like um
if you're like driving the train so
michael sandel says you're driving the
train and you can
you can turn the you can turn the wheel
and it goes into one person instead of
five people and that's instead of the
lever right so
most people say yeah they would turn
they would turn the wheel they'd go into
the one person instead of five but they
wouldn't push the fat man
and one of the students says but look i
mean the difference is like there's a
difference between like turning the
wheel
and like actually like getting your
hands on a man and pushing him off the
thing and so michael sandell says well
what if the fat man is kind of on a trap
door
and the way to open the trap door is to
grab a big wheel and you just turn the
wheels
and it's like okay yeah i still probably
wouldn't do that right
and but again the reason i bring this up
is to say like
i think it's fair to say that maybe like
most people
wouldn't would pull the lever but
wouldn't push the fat man but
surely if if the principle is the same
then you should do the same thing in
either situation
or is there a difference like you know
what's going on there and
interestingly like there have been
studies done where people have undergone
an mri scan
whilst being asked the trolley problem
and
when they think about like the lever so
okay so so
the people who say that they would both
pull the lever and push the fat man
when they're thinking about the question
the parts of their brain associated with
rationality are lighting up
for the people who say that they would
pull the lever but wouldn't push the fat
man when they're thinking about the
questions the emotional parts of the
brain
are lighting up right implying that
actually yeah no no the
the reason you wouldn't push the fat man
is actually because of like you know
your emotional tendency to what you
would and wouldn't do rather than your
rational thinking about what you should
and shouldn't do
but okay there are some situations in
which i can give you two situations
which are like
almost exactly the same and yet you
would say that one is right and one is
wrong
um let's say for example you're an
ambulance driver
and you've got two people in the back
and they need to get to hospital
immediately
right and if you don't get there
immediately they're gonna die
as you're driving along you look out the
window and you see
a boulder just rolling rolling towards
an innocent man
right now what you could do is you could
stop the ambulance you could get out of
the ambulance you could push the boulder
out of the way and you'd save the
innocent man
but you shouldn't do that right you
should stay driving because then the two
people in the back of the ambulance are
going to die
so you stay you stay in the ambulance
you think i wish i could save that man
but i can't
i'm willing to like allow him to die so
that i can make sure that these two guys
get to hospital right fair
would you say busy day analysis fairly
busy day yeah
i hope that guy gets a pay rise um but
now imagine
same situation except this time you're
driving the ambulance two people in the
back
and there's a boulder in the way
it's in the road and the only way to to
keep moving forward is to
is to kind of push the boulder so that
it rolls and kills an innocent man
are you allowed to do that
seems like maybe not like i don't know
if an ambulance driver was riding along
like he like that would be a good thing
to do you just kind of
bump into the thing and make it hit the
other you probably say no but like
what's the difference like what is the
difference between
between allowing a boulder to kill an
innocent man saved people in the back
and pushing the boulder into the
innocent man saved people in the back in
both situations
you decide whether the innocent man
lives or dies and the basis in which you
make that decision
is you know with reference to the people
in the back of the ambulance so what is
the difference
is it not the continuation the the point
at which you enter into the story
and the effect that you have moving
forward sure
so this is the distinction of doing and
allowing
and this is where this i've stumbled
upon some ethics
yeah well this i mean this is this is
kind of the the analysis that's given
it's like well there's a difference
between doing and allowing there's a
difference between
allowing a bad thing to happen and being
the cause of a bad thing to happen but
my god like it gets it gets worse it
gets it gets even more complicated than
that because like
you've got to decide like how are you
defining the difference between doing
and allowing like what
what really is the difference there for
example you know
if i walk up to somebody who is attached
to a life support machine and i unplug
them
have i killed them or i allowed them to
die
because like you know the machine was
was okay
so maybe you could think something like
if you're the doctor yeah
and you're the one who plugs in the
machine then by taking out the machine
you're allowing them to die because they
were going to die anyway you're stopping
them from dying by plugging it in
when you unplug it you allow them to die
but if the doctor plugs it in
and then walks away and then another
person comes in and unplugs it
they're probably killing the person
right that would be
but what surely it can't be the
difference between doing and allowing
can't be like who's
who's doing the action right that can't
be it but like that seems to that seems
to be a
difficult intuition to to um
to to think about but also like i mean
um
i wrote a paper about this once for one
of my tutors and and
basically said like the distinction is a
bunk one it doesn't make any sense
like if i take it to his extreme i could
say something like
if i come up and slit your throat i'm
not killing you i'm allowing you to die
because like
i'm just removing the barrier of your
blood that's kind of keeping it from
like spurting everywhere right
like it's a similar it's a similar kind
of thing like for instance you could say
take the life support machine if instead
of like a mechanical
exterior electronic thing that plugs
into the wall let's say that we managed
to kind of
grow a cellular life support machine
right so someone's on life support and
we design a kind of technology that says
we can
we can take like a pill that they take
that causes them to like grow a certain
kind of
organ or something which acts in the
same way as the life support machine
does
if that person's just walking down the
street minding their own business and i
come up to them with a knife
and i cut it out of them surely i've
killed them
but like it's the same it's the same
thing
right all i've actually done is removed
the barrier
that was keeping them alive so i just
allowed them to die
right now earlier from the thought
experiment with the ambulance driver it
seems to be that there is a moral
distinction not just like a like a
physical because right now we're talking
about the non-moral distinction we're
just talking about what is the
descriptive difference between doing and
allowing but
once you've done that you then have to
determine whether it's morally relevant
or not so we've already seen that like
there seems to be a morally relevant
difference
between doing and allowing it seems to
be that allowing is less
bad than doing but then like
what does that mean for like kind of
cutting out someone's organ or something
like is that
is that not as bad as somehow killing
them in another way or something like
that like it's
it's like it's not as simple as people
think it is right because
this is this is the explanation we go
through because i give you the thought
experiment with the boulder and your
answer is
well i mean surely the difference is
that in one case you're kind of putting
yourself into the situation
you're doing rather than allowing but
it's like yeah but i could
i could say the same thing about slaying
someone's filling someone's throat or
something
like that right like i'm not entirely
sure that's the case but also
um sometimes we would think that
uh allowing someone to die is just as
bad as killing them so for instance
peter singer gives the example of the
child drowning in the in the shallow
pond
imagine for example this is his famous
example from him if you're walking down
the street and there's like a really
shallow pond next to you
and there's a child drowning in the
shallow pond and you could go and save
that child really easily
but you decide not to because you don't
want to ruin your shoes you just bought
them and they cost you 30 quid
you're an immoral monster right that's a
horrible thing to do
so it's really really bad because you've
allowed this child to die because you
refused
to intervene at the cost of 30 pounds
but that's what you do every single time
you refuse to give 30 pounds to charity
the child isn't drowning in front of you
the child is starving on the other side
of the world
and you're saying no i'm not going to
intervene because i want to keep my 30
pounds
what's the difference between that and
walking past the child in the shallow
pond and saying i'm not going to
intervene because i don't want to ruin
my shoes which cost me 30 pounds
it's distance it's a lack of directness
or feeling like you are direct this is
how it is at least in people
so let's take that one by one we take
the distance case okay so a child
um drowning in ethiopia
is on the other side of the globe okay
what if they're drowning in morocco
what about spain what about france what
about wales
what if it was like what if it was just
what it feels like in the next village
along
what if it was like next door and you
had to kind of go outside and knock on
the door and get the
like how close how close does it have to
be like what
surely distance doesn't make a
difference
if like the money that you can give will
get to its destination easily it's not
like you have to go over to ethiopia or
something it's like
you can just donate the money online you
can do it from your laptop it would be
less effort for you
to donate 30 30 pounds to
oxfam than to go and like save a child
from drowning in a puddle right
but we seem to think that you have to
save the child from the puddle but you
don't have to give money to charity
and peter singer uses this to say that
essentially you taking 30 pounds
that you could have you refusing to send
life-saving treatment to a child for no
good reason
is just the same as you posting them
cyanide
you're just putting some cyanide in in
the mail and shooting it over there and
killing them like
it's like it's like what is the moral
difference why is it that just because
in one case you're
allowing them to die because you don't
want to intervene and in the other case
you're causing them to die because
you're
actually doing the intervention like
what's the moral difference here
why is one okay and whatnot why do you
have the right to
allow a child to die of malaria but you
don't have the right to allow
a child to die from suffocation from
drowning
it's interesting when you come across
people
who have thought about this stuff
thoroughly and then have the conviction
of their efforts to go after it so two
examples
first one being yourself you became
convinced of
bing bing fifth time lucky veganism um
through
a like just an armchair philosophy sort
of thought framework
desperately asked youtube to see if
someone out there could find a rebuttal
that would mean that you didn't have to
go vegan
then didn't stuck to your guns and went
vegan the other
equivalent is toby odd this guy that
wrote the precipice and in his episode
with sam harris
uh he said toby ord and i quote his
publishers bloomsbury who owe me an
absolute [ __ ] tongue so i keep putting
their authors on the show
he's not doing press the week he went on
i'm not no no
no he's not not doing press he's just
not doing press that isn't sam harris
anyway not not that i'm bitter toby if
you're listening
um uh he is one of the key figures in
the effective altruism
movement yeah have you seen this where
people commit
like 20 like significant portions of
their
earnings for the rest of their life and
then they find them
the most effective charity that they
could give it to they maximize the value
out of every pound
and people are giving like real
significant portions of the wealth
forever and they're like tied into like
the sort of lifetime contract thing
um he's another person similar to
yourself presumably
has gone through thought experiments
like this surrounded by
[ __ ] nick bostrom who's just bending
his mind and um
yet the end result is you know
10 20 of his salary for
the rest of time to yeah effective well
this is that this is the thing like
the the reason we do ethics we should
remember is to figure out the right way
to live
right this is essentially why we do
ethics to figure out what the right
things to do is if you're just doing
ethics in such a way and you think of it
as kind of a
philosophical play thing then like fine
but
i i think it's far more beneficial to
use ethics to determine how you actually
live your life so if you come to a
conclusion
and it seems really abstract right it
seems like
driving an ambulance and you've got
people and then there's like a rock just
materializes
but you realize that by answering that
question that can lead you to the
conclusion ah so i should give up ten
percent of my income to charity
dangerous some of the things it's like
it's like actually yeah no that that
makes sense you know and maybe you
should then do that but then if you
become convinced that's the case and
it's like
then act act in accordance with it if
somebody if you become ethically
convinced
that it's wrong to kill animals then
stop killing animals if you become
ethically convinced
there's no difference between refusing
to give 30 quid to oxfam
and you know refusing to to save the
child in the puddle then give 30 quid to
oxfam
you know like it should be actually
determining our actions albert camus in
the myth of sisyphus says that for the
man who does not cheat
what he determines to be true must
determine his actions
and that sentence almost single-handedly
made me go vegan
what a bastard i am i'm going to tell
you a story because i didn't ever get
around to it i texted you while i was in
ibiza
um about this but um i was away with
ricky my buddy we were having a great
day we'd had
um a day sort of exploring the island
who went out for dinner with the
the photographer and his misses that
were there on the night time she's vegan
he's keto and uh ricky is
a ex-raf um
a soldier and uh like classic sort of
crossfit guy
um and i found myself
promulgating your position putting
forward your
moral philosophy position on veganism um
as i had two non-vegans and one vegan
sat around
um and i was saying all of the stuff
that there's
what is the characteristic that an
animal lacks that if a human lacked blah
blah
and everything that we went through if
you haven't if you don't know what i'm
talking about check out alex's channel
check out his last episode on my show
which will be linked in the show notes
below
um and i found myself and then his
missus piped up and was like so what
like
why do you still eat meat yeah and it it
came back to the
the um practical implication which i
think we keep coming back to
and i keep um trying to impress on you
because i think that it is
at least for me the kryptonite that has
meant
something i'm convinced of hasn't been
something that i've taken as a lifestyle
change
which is the amount of effort that is
required to do it
um is simply practically highly
inconvenient
and because the path of least resistance
and there's a lot of inertia to overcome
with that
uh that i tend to not do it but i said i
held my hands up and it's weird
when you say something that's kind of in
homage to someone that's a friend
but they're not there to hear it um
which is kind of an interesting sort of
situation to be
a part of i was like look man like i
know that i'm living out of alignment
with things that i know to be true
right i believe i believe that
uh increasingly now convinced that as
you say
people in the future will look back on
what we do
with animals in terms of factory farming
now as
an absolute travesty and yet
the food that i ordered was a chicken
bacon pizza and yes and the other um
so yeah it was it was interesting it's
interesting uh to
to see people like yourself and like uh
toby odd
who don't just sort of talk the talk
but they they put their yeah they put
their money and their uh
vegetables where their mouth is yeah
well it's
why bother like why bother doing any of
this investigation if
you're not gonna allow it to inform your
actions like it would be like kind of
spending years and years and years
trying to figure out the best way to
develop
nuclear technology and then you finally
work it out when you go
ah can't really be bothered to do it i
mean it's a lot of effort you know it's
like
then then why bother do the
investigations in the first place i
would say look remember difficulty is a
relative term
if i offered you five pounds to
run a marathon that's that's that's
that's a difficult thing to do for five
pounds but if i offered you a million
pounds to run a marathon it's probably
the easiest million dollars you've ever
made
right it's like the term difficult is
relative
to the consequences of the action right
like
in relative to the suffering that you'll
save by going vegan
the difficulty level is is like nothing
and we don't allow that that kind of
uh those kind of reasoning and that kind
of excuse making to be taken seriously
on any other ethical issue
i mean like any other ethical issue that
you choose if you're talking about
theft you could be talking about
domestic abuse or something if someone
was just like look i agree that it's
wrong it's just a lot of effort to
change it it's like well tough
ethics isn't supposed to be easy if
something's wrong then stop doing it
it's not like it's impossible for you
right it's like it's inconvenient yeah
well
you know what else is inconvenient being
put in a gas chamber
like i i think i have a bit more
sympathy for the pig there than i do for
you i'm afraid to say
um and it's worth it it's worth just
remembering that like but
okay the worst part is that like it's
not really fair that i lump that on you
because i was talking to a friend of
mine the other day at the pub and
he's not a vegan and the rest of us
there were vegan we were talking about
it and we ended up having a big
discussion about it by the end of the
night we're outside just going we'll
just just
you know just do it you know you know
that's wrong you know and then
i saw someone who didn't know like a
stranger kind of go past and on his
motorbike or something you know when you
see someone drive past and
you've never met them but you just look
at them and think i just i know that i
don't like that person
um it was it was like it was one of
those situations and i thought to myself
that guy eats me
no but i thought i thought here i am i
thought here i am like i'm here with my
friend who's one of the nicest people i
know
one of the nicest people i know and here
i am like lambasting him
for his dietary choices that guy is
going to go and eat me and he's not
going to suffer for it at all it's like
why am i punishing you for being my
friend
you know like this doesn't seem fair it
doesn't seem fair that i i should i
should lay this on you and i'm not going
to go and lay it on the stranger why
should he get away
for the rest of his life never even
having to consider that eating meat is
wrong
but you don't get a get to get away with
that because you had the misfortune to
meet me and now like
this is on your mind every time you go
and buy some milk and
it it it annoyed me it frustrated me
because i thought
this isn't fair on on people this isn't
fair on people that just by chance they
happen to have
met the wrong person who now is putting
this in the head then i also thought
well no because like
by telling you about this and by saying
it bluntly it's like it's an indication
of
how much i respect you as someone who
who wants to better themselves who wants
to get rid of false beliefs who wants to
adopt more true beliefs and live in line
with with
a virtuous ethic and it's like
everything that i see you do you know
like when you're tweeting about things
and you're posting instagram posts and
sometimes they're motivational sometimes
that like you you said earlier um
something like always avoid stupidity
right and it's like yeah it's it's
pretty stupid to think that you had that
you're justified in torturing an animal
so that you can have a bit of bacon if
you want to avoid stupidity
then you know avoid it if you want to
avoid stupidity then avoid mcdonald's
you know like
it's like and i realized that i'm
justified
in talking to you in this manner because
it's it's not an attack it's a it's a
like
look man i see what you're trying to do
and i reckon like i respect you enough
to know that that you can do better and
this is how i think you could do it and
that's just that's just one man's
opinion like
you know who am i to tell you how to
live your life well i'm not but i'm
telling you how i'm here tell you how
i've
how i live my life why i live my life in
that way and how it's benefited me and
how i think it could benefit you too and
then it's up to you
as to whether you want to make that
decision or not and when history looks
back as peter singer says
you'll be counted among the oppressors
of the liberators and you've got to make
that choice and i love it alex today's
been awesome man thank you so much for
coming on
uh where should people go they want to
watch something
why don't you um if if people to watch
one video of yours
what would you recommend they go onto
your channel say search cosmic skeptic
which will be linked in the show notes
below
um what videos should i put in there if
there were one i would i would recommend
um the one that i have is the channel
trailer is a speech i gave in tel aviv
uh called why it's time to go vegan um
and it's one of my proudest videos
just because i think it landed quite
well people seem to like the speech
other than that there's a video i made
called a meat eater's case of veganism
which
a lot of people i think that's how you
found me in there because that's the
video we originally
discussed um that's one of my favorite
videos uh to talk about
like ethics and stuff you know i used to
be more about philosophy of religion
atheism that kind of stuff but i could
care less at this point if you believe
in god if you're still like paying for
animals to be
tortured so like those are the most
important things but you know the second
link under that would definitely be
patreon.com forward slash cosmic skeptic
that's the
you know make sure that that's uh that's
that's also in the
link in the description and you have a
patreon too now which i'm which i'm so
glad to hear about i know indeed i know
indeed man
all because of you all because of you um
so yeah everything will be linked in the
show notes below oh final thing actually
so you mentioned about the
uh gentleman from america whose book was
a good read
um as a basis for ethics michael sandel
yeah anything else that you think easy
intro
or just an interesting myth of sisyphus
i guess uh i'm not sure if that's the
easiest
intro it's about the i mean it's about
the philosophy of
suicide which can be a bit much um
i would recommend if you're just looking
to get into ethics michael sandell's
justice is a good place to start you can
also read peter singer's practical
ethics
uh where he he goes over and kind of
discusses what does equality mean um
when is it okay to kill you know like
all of these kind of
these kind of questions it's a really
good introduction um
practical ethics by peter singer if
you're interested in the discussions on
utilitarianism that we've been having
then
uh roger crisp's book mill on
utilitarianism is the analysis
that's worth reading and i think if you
want to read utilitarianism by john
stuart mill
it's worth reading it alongside crisps
analysis or reading crisps analysis
first just to make sure you kind of
understand everything that mill is
getting at and understand that marcus
aurelius's meditations where you need to
have like
someone or someone along for the ride
who can actually explain what's going on
yeah you probably want to make sure that
you actually know what you're reading it
it's like a lot of times you're reading
like
um old philosophy you you probably want
to read it with
some kind of uh some kind of analysis
not because it's necessarily because
it's difficult for philosophy because
the language has changed like people
meant different things by different
words you need to make sure you
understand what people
uh what people are saying um yeah ethics
wise i think
i'm just looking at the the ethics
section of my oh ethics in the real
world is also a good collection of
essays by peter singer as well
um you can probably tell i mean peter
singer is is one of the most influential
things
on my thinking in my life ethics in the
real world are
a series of very short essays on very
particular ethical questions
like you know should you refer to in
news stories should you refer to animals
as
who or that so like you know should you
say the cow that or the cow
who like very specific questions across
a broad range of different philosophical
issues
um and it's quite an interesting read so
those are some recommendations that i'd
give to get people going
cool awesome alex mann thank you so much
uh
we're gonna have to find somewhere else
i'm gonna have to get something else to
to pull you back on about yoga
or whatever the uh next adventure is
that we take postcards
yeah about that yeah at any time man
it's always good to speak to you um if
you ever need me to come and talk about
veganism or something or
something or anything or veganism that's
fine yeah i don't mind all veganism
anything all veganism
veganism has everything because veganism
is my everything
my one my love yeah i love my eye
well i hope it's i hope it's non-gmo
apple because uh
yeah it's organic um whatever the
latest free range yeah grass-fed
apple of my eye yeah man thank you for
your time cheers dude
very nice and then very slowly stopping
in the hands
[Music]
and you start thinking
you